[Musique]
aussi grosse enquête de façon
internationale non
cette semaine je vais vous raconter
l'histoire de Sébastien Vachon
Desjardins fonctionnaire le jour méga
pirate informatique internationale le
soir on allait aussi voler les données
de l'entreprise l'année de naissance
social et donner médical
[Musique]
la note qui a été laissée par le pirate
informatique c'est baveux poli courtois
bon jeune homme de bonne famille et
pourtant pour le FBI et la GRC c'était
le cybercriminel arrêté le jour de
l'opération on peut dire que le ciel est
tombé complètement sur la tête il a mis
des villes des écoles des entreprises à
genoux extorquer 30 millions de dollars
en quelques mois seulement en faisant
des victimes dans plus de 33 pays et
finalement c'était pas un bon plan pour
devenir millionnaire et si Marie monte
Denis bienvenue à enquête
les Québécois viennent ici pour ça en
grande majorité mais aujourd'hui le
Québécois en Floride que nous cherchons
est ici à la Cour fédérale en
combinaison orange de prisonniers
savaient-ils que c'est comme ça que ça
finirait
toi a débuté le 17 janvier 2021 un
dimanche j'ai un gestionnaire qui
roulait travailler ce week-end là et
puis c'est à ce moment-là qu'il a
remarqué que tout était figé et n'avait
pas accès à distance à son poste de
travail
il a contacté notre technicien
informatique et c'est en ouvrant son
poste de travail qu'une note
apparaissait d'un pirate informatique
avec une demande de rançon le pirate
dans sa rançon demandait un million de
dollars donc c'est là que les problèmes
ont débuté
que c'était quelqu'un de Gatineau
finalement qui était affilié au rançon
logiciel ça fera plaisir qu'un seul
individu peut créer autant de temps pour
une organisation
[Musique]
c'est notre salle des serveurs qui avait
été attaqué donc
où toute l'information finalement avait
été saisie par le pirate
d'habitude mon mamie inspire la détente
le contraire de ce qu'a véhicule
directeur général Félix Michaud l'an
dernier le 17 janvier 2021 la ville de
Montmagny a été victime d'une
cyberattaque on était en pleine période
de pandémie donc que c'est comme une
crevaison sur l'autoroute c'est jamais
le bon moment
non plus un mastoyage dans un centre de
recherche du ceget de Saint-Félicien on
enseigne l'art et la science de la
fourrure c'est concret c'est tangible ça
contraste avec la menace immatérielle
des cyberattaques jusqu'au jour où c'est
devenu très concret au Cégep de
Saint-Félicien ça s'est passé dans la
nuit du 17 septembre moi je me suis
présenté au travail le 18 septembre au
matin rapidement j'ai constaté qu'il y
avait plusieurs choses qui
fonctionnaient plus je suis en réunion
mon directeur de l'informatique arrive à
peu préoccuper donc me demande vraiment
de me retirer l'annonce que l'entièreté
de nos serveurs estime de nos boîtes
courriels rétentrypter
sérieusement c'était pour moi la fin du
monde à 2000 km de Saint-Félicien dans
une petite ville de lillinois jolie
Pride et paf Robinson dirigent ce centre
de santé communautaire elles vivent le
même cauchemar une marque
on dans le centre d'opérations d'urgence
covid quelqu'un du service de
l'informatique m'annonce qu'on a été
attaqué et que nos documents sont gelés
il y a beaucoup de personnes dans notre
communauté qui comptent sur nous
c'était comme recevoir un coup de poing
dans le ventre j'ai arrêté moins surpris
si une tornade avait détruit notre
bâtiment
au moment où on a compris qu'on était
sous-attaque notre premier réflexe pour
nous a été vraiment d'appeler nos
autorités ministérielles elles nous ont
dirigée vers une firme spécialisée au
niveau de la cybérateur
[Musique]
Jean-Sébastien Beaulieu reçoit la pelle
je m'appelle Jean-Sébastien Beaulieu
j'ai travaillé comme vice-président de
la firme forensique qui a aidé le Cégep
de Saint-Félicien lors de son incident
quand on est arrivé à Saint-Félicien il
y avait des ordinateurs qui étaient
empilés sur les bureaux dans ce
moment-là on peut travailler des 15 des
20h par jour pour essayer de rétablir la
situation le run somewher et basé sur la
pression psychologique qu'on peut mettre
sur une entreprise sur des individus
tous les moyens sont utilisés pour
mettre la pression pour payer la rançon
[Musique]
j'étais déjà tellement sous pression
avec la covid ça a été la pire chose de
toute ma carrière professionnelle et
puis même de ma vie personnelle ça
s'appelait
parler de networker
Twer un groupe de pirates informatiques
qui travaillent ensemble quelque part
dans les méandres de l'Internet caché
c'est une organisation criminelle
hautement organisée qui se spécialise
dans l'extorsion et ont deux grands
modèles opératoires le premier c'est la
prise en otage du système informatique
et le deuxième c'est l'extraction
d'information le vol d'information pour
ensuite mettre la pression pour négocier
une rançon mais pour l'heure c'est la
gestion de crise ça a été disons source
de stress d'anxiété cette période là qui
est impacté il fallait faire autrement à
essayer de maintenir ce service aux
citoyens à titre d'exemple le Service
des finances un shutdown complet c'est
pas juste les postes de travail c'est
les imprimantes les photocopieurs la
téléphonie tout ce qui est relié à un
réseau donc les comptes de taxes ont dû
être retardés à partir de cette attaque
là on a pu accès à rien on peut plus
travailler ce qui reste c'est un tableau
une craie
du papier ça pouvait pas arriver à
Pierre moment parce qu'on était en
pleine session ceux qui viennent nous
voir sont pour la plupart des familles à
faibles revenus même si cela ne règle
pas leurs problèmes à court terme le
Centre de santé de lillinois porte
plainte une fois nos systèmes gelés on a
appelé le FBI
[Musique]
je m'appelle Michaelson j'ai travaillé
25 ans pour le FBI notamment comme agent
spécial responsable du bureau de Tampa
en Floride une entreprise dans la région
des Tempah a été attaquée par networker
c'est comme ça qu'on l'a découvert c'est
à partir de là que ma cyber équipe a
commencé à enquêter
est composé de développeurs de logiciels
malveillants et d'affilier qui mène les
attaques
si les rangs sont payés il est partage
généralement entre 70 et 80% pour la
filier et le reste pour le développement
les affiliés laissent une note dans le
système des victimes pour leur dire
qu'ils ont été infectés par leur
rançongiciel et voici les messages qu'on
reçu nos victimes
[Musique]
on se dit c'est une blague faut que ça
soit une blague et là quand on a fait le
tour de ce qui se passait c'était pas
une blague
il demande des rançons en Bitcoin
quand on a su qu'il fallait payer une
rançon en Bitcoin je n'avais aucune idée
de ce que c'était comment ça
fonctionnait où en trouver
[Musique]
en fait ça me rendait plus nerveuse de
savoir comment on allait trouver des
Bitcoin payer la rançon le pirate va
défaut d'avoir une rançon et menaçait de
publier sur le Dark web des informations
sensibles donc la possibilité de payer
une rançon ça faisait partie des options
possibles si on n'avait pas payé la
rançon on aurait été dans le pétrin tout
un dilemme à évaluer c'est ici dans ce
blog que les membres de networker
publient les informations volées quand
les victimes refusent de payer l'un des
pirates l'usager 128 et particulièrement
actif mais où est-il
franchir plusieurs étapes pour découvrir
de qui ça venait
l'enquête du FBI démarre à Tampa en
Floride c'est ici que l'usager 128
attaque une entreprise de
télécommunication en mai 2020 128 laisse
un premier indice une adresse liée à un
serveur en Pologne
d'où provenaient les attaques et on a
déterminé le nom de la personne puis 128
frappes à nouveau deux nouvelles
victimes en Californie lors de ses
attaques 128 laisse d'autres traces qui
mènent à un deuxième serveur en Pologne
un poteau rose plein d'indices pour
découvrir que 128 est au Canada au
Québec à Gatineau ici dans cette maison
[Musique]
et on s'est mis à travailler avec la
Gendarmerie royale du Canada
[Musique]
je constate avec la GRC dans la division
de cybercriminalité dans la région de
Toronto en août 2020 mon super bizarre
approché puis il m'a dit que on a reçu
un appel du FBI il y avait un dossier de
rançon logiciel qui est impliquait un
Canadien le super vivant en banlieue de
Gatineau c'était quelqu'un qui est
devenu
multimillionnaire très rapidement
le monsieur Sébastien Vachon Desjardins
Sébastien Vachon Desjardins 33 ans
resident Gatineau la place de Sébastien
Vachon Desjardins dans le groupe
networker c'était un affilié notre rôle
au départ avec le FBI ils nous ont
demandé seulement de l'identifier
Sébastien était probablement le plus
grand affilié du réseau networker
c'était une première pour nous pour
notre unité surtout en cybercriminalité
probablement le plus gros dossier au
Canada au niveau durant son logiciel
au retour la vie improbable de Sébastien
Vachon Desjardins fonctionnaires pirate
informatique et trafiquant de drogue
aussi
c'est un cachette de drogue qui était
vraiment
imposante il y en avait pour un demi
million de stupéfiants
[Musique]
peuvent bien il veut déjà arrêter
Sébastien Vachon Desjardins et demande
l'assistance du Canada la GRC va
découvrir qu'il y a des victimes de ce
côté-ci de la frontière aussi
le constable François Picard Blais de la
GRC devient l'un des deux enquêteurs
principaux
il faut il est bases de données
policière ce que je découvre c'est que
il avait des accusations de trafic de
stupéfiants contre lui de la police de
Gatineau
Sébastien Bachchan Desjardins c'est
quelqu'un qui flash pour
ces personnes qui s'entraînent vos James
de bonheur quartier résidentiel ben
normal pas de gros chat va pas au
restaurant donc là c'est difficile à
comprendre
[Musique]
au Service de police de la Ville de
Gatineau depuis 28 ans puis j'ai procédé
à l'arrestation de Sébastien Vachon
Desjardins à trois recueils
[Musique]
en 2015 on a été un endroit suite à une
information reçue de façon anonyme du
public on va constater que chez
Sébastien il y avait des sacs qui
entrait puis qui sortaient on est allé
chez lui puis là on a découvert une
cachette de drogue qui était vraiment
imposante
en valeur sur la rue il y en avait pour
un demi million de stupéfiants
c'est sûr et certain qu'il est devenu
important dans le milieu criminel
Sébastien Vachon Desjardins et surnommé
gâteaux par certains acolytes
[Musique]
en référence à la célèbre marque de
petits gâteaux qui portent son nom
parlons gâteau la cerise pour Denis
Simard c'est d'apprendre ce que
Sébastien fait dans la vie quand il ne
trafique pas de drogue à ma surprise on
a découvert que c'est un employé du
gouvernement fédéral travailler du côté
de Ottawa à plusieurs reprises de
nissima apprend le suspect en filature
jusqu'à son travail Sébastien et
technicien en informatique au Centre
national de recherche du Canada à Ottawa
lorsqu'on l'interroger il y avait peur
de perdre son emploi au gouvernement
d'autres qui est à la prison après
l'avoir arrêté si tu dis ok bon ben là
il va avoir
il va faire son temps on va essayer de
le remettre sur le droit chemin mais ça
a pas été le cas je m'attendais pas à ce
qui recommence à nouveau aucunement
Sébastien Vachon Desjardins est libéré
de prison en 2016 et réussi à réintégrer
la fonction publique son nouvel
employeur service et approvisionnement
Canada n'a pas voulu nous dire si on
avait vérifié ces antécédents trois ans
c'est cool en novembre 2019 à ma grande
surprise j'ai su que Sébastien Vachon de
jardin était à nouveau un employé du
gouvernement fédéral puis que était de
retour dans le monde des stupéfiants
comme trafiquants en grande quantité
donc à partir de là
j'en ai fait une priorité
on a débuté de la surveillance sur
Sébastien
même résidence
un dimanche Sébastien Vachon de jardin
c'est rendu avec sa conjoint dans le
secteur de Repentigny à l'intersection
la 640 puis de la 40
rencontre il redescendu de Repentigny
j'ai tant de position pour vérifier le
temps qui est arrivé
mais il est sorti un baril brun en
carton avec un anneau métallique qui
était très lourd c'est des produits qui
sont transportés pour faire de la
méthamphétamine c'est évident que c'est
un fournisseur majeur dans la région
donc quand on l'a l'air était là il
était vraiment
découragé là il pensait vraiment pas que
la police est en arrière de lui en
février 2020 Sébastien est donc arrêté à
nouveau pour trafic de drogue mais les
accusations vont suivre quelques mois
plus tard il est donc en liberté et
toujours fonctionnaire pour le moment ça
ça fait pas partie de notre mandats donc
à ce moment-là je pense pas que son
employeur était au courant et dans les
semaines suivantes Sébastien va
décrocher un autre emploi parallèle le
groupe networker recrute une annonce en
alphabet cyrillique paraît sur les
forums que fréquente Sébastien il est et
se met à la tâche son ascension au sein
de sa nouvelle entreprise criminelle
sera fulgurante et en juin 2020 il
participe à une très grosse attaque en
Californie
[Musique]
on était au sommet de la pandémie du
coronavirus un groupe appelé networker
qu'on croyait basé en Russie a réussi à
entrer dans le système informatique de
l'université de San Francisco à Londres
le journaliste techno de la BBC Joe tidy
suit l'attaque en direct
clandestin qui mène à leur portail de
négociation
j'ai pu assister à la négociation que
s'est déroulé entre l'université et les
pirates
vise le centre de recherche qui tente de
développer un vaccin contre la
covidité
essayez vraiment de trouver un vaccin
pour sauver des vies
et ses pirates cruellement les extorqués
les pirates demandent 3 millions
l'université offre 750 000 dollars
américains
vous pouvez le garder c'est rien pour
nous elle a acheté du McDonald's à vos
employés il disait que c'était passé
compte tenu de tout le travail qu'ils
ont fait et je me suis dit vous n'avez
pas travaillé vous vous êtes introduit
dans les systèmes de l'université vous
êtes des criminels
l'université annonce publiquement
qu'elle a été attaquée et qu'elle a payé
une rançon l'équivalent d'un million de
dollars américains en Bitcoin
[Musique]
de la population en ce moment-là essayez
de comprendre la covid les hôpitaux
plein la pénurie d'infirmières et
l'épuisement mental des gens
judiciaire assez pitoyable à mon avis
le FBI est d'autant plus motivé à
trouver le coupable au cours de
multiples attaques auxquelles il prend
part Sébastien a laissé des indices
importants qui permettront de découvrir
l'une de ces adresses courriels.com
[Musique]
une référence aux personnages de
skyrunter un cyber intimidateur dans la
série South Park une trouvaille qui mène
à une autre exploration des références
culturelles de Sébastien
[Musique]
le FBI trouve une autre adresse qui lui
est liée boom shake à la
callac@hotmail.com
lorsque la GRC en 35 au mois d'août 2020
on sera vite compte que le loup est dans
la bergerie du gouvernement du Canada
problème
c'était assez délicat à ce moment-là
c'était assez important de pouvoir
mitiger le risque puis l'accès qui avait
en tant que employé du gouvernement du
Canada il fallait garder en quête
secrète alors Monsieur Vachon de jardin
était dans une situation assez précaire
à ce moment-là il y avait la police de
Gatineau qui était après lui il y avait
le FBI qu'il recherchait puis ensuite il
y avait nous qui venait avec notre
nouvelle enquête mais pour les
Américains le temps commence à presser
[Musique]
je m'appelle cartoon Games je suis
procureur fédéral à Tempah en Floride
j'étais le procureur principal de cette
enquête criminelle
on voulait extrader monsieur Vachon
Desjardins le plus tôt possible parce
qu'on voulait mettre fin au rang son
logiciel de networker
avec les agents de la GRC on essayait
certainement de faire pression pour
qu'il bouge le plus vite possible et il
comprenait ce ne sont pas les États-Unis
qui décident ce sont les autorités
canadiennes
on n'ira pas défoncer des portes ou
mettre des menottes c'est le travail de
la police locale
et c'est ainsi qu'en janvier 2021
Sébastien va renouer avec le bon vieux
lieutenant Simard de la police de
Gatineau
un appel
la JRC de la région de Toronto puis là
c'est à ce moment-là qui m'ont mentionné
qui faisait l'objet d'un enquête avec le
FBI
concernait des rançons logiciels donc là
j'ai été
[Musique]
si je pourrais dire estomac King j'étais
vraiment exceptionnel
de penser que ce petit gars
oui c'est un gros trafiquant mais que il
est amené aussi grosse enquête de façon
internationale non quand ils m'ont dit
que j'étais pour procéder à son
arrestation
pour le FBI l'enquête mais pour moi
c'est du jamais vu c'est un peu comme
comparaison l'autre c'est vraiment un
gros là dans toute ma carrière je
m'attendais jamais
a été impliqué dans un dossier avec le
FBI
[Musique]
découv
re chez Sébastien
il y avait beaucoup d'argent
qui était surtout dans son garde-robe
dans sa chambre à coucher on parle de
300000 dollars en cash
[Musique]
bon bien les carottes sont pas mal
cuites pour Sébastien Vachon Desjardins
mais les policiers vont faire le saut
quand ils vont réaliser combien d'argent
il a accumulé en quelques mois seulement
avec ses attaques de rançon-jiciel
mais d'abord retournons voir nos
victimes pâte et Giuli doivent prendre
la décision
alors on s'est dit qu'est-ce qu'on fait
est-ce qu'on le fait c'est jamais une
bonne idée de céder au chantage mais on
était plus fonctionnel on n'avait pas le
temps de niaiser
on a fini par payer et ça a donné
quelque chose comme 45 Bitcoin c'est
comme 370 000 dollars j'étais nerveuse
et si on paye et on a récupéré pas nos
données
c'était stressant il n'y a pas de
garantie quand on a affaire à des
criminels ce n'est pas comme avoir un
contrat signé dans les films avec des
prises d'otages des fois ça finit mal
ensuite ils nous ont envoyé une clé de
déchiffrement il nous a fallu six jours
pour tout récupérer
c'est un sujet tabou mais plusieurs
experts nous ont confirmé que bon nombre
de victimes paix j'ai eu des clients qui
ont décidé de pas payer la rançon j'ai
eu des clients qui se sont vu dans
l'obligation de payer la rançon
probablement un peu plus que 50% on
payait la rançon dans mes expériences
possibles et c'est des millions des
dizaines ça des centaines de millions de
dollars qui vont au prime organiser sa
cliente la directrice du Cégep de
Saint-Félicien a pris sa décision nous
avons décidé
autant avec les gens de l'équipe
ministérielle et nous de ne pas ouvrir
la rançon parce que on ne souhaitait pas
payer je n'ai même pas voulu le savoir
combien était le montant c'était clair
qu'on allait pas payer l'impact là c'est
pas juste financier c'est vraiment c'est
des gens qui sont derrière ça moi je me
souviens avoir vu certaines de mes
ressources s'effondrer pleurer mais il y
avait aussi ce sentiment le titre de
onde de d'échec s'il y a eu un cri du
cœur qui s'est fait aussi c'était
vraiment impensable de pouvoir donner de
l'argent aux crèmes organisées
pour le cégep c'est à clair la priorité
stade rétablir les systèmes rapidement
pour pouvoir desserver les étudiants ils
ont bien fait de pas payer leur rançon
à mon manie le directeur général Félix
Michaud il est encore un ego suivait son
cours mais un événement est prévu vient
tout changer au moment où on évaluait le
paiement d'une rançon il y a eu
l'annonce du département de la Justice
des États-Unis la saisie des actifs et
des serveurs durant son logiciel
networker donc c'est à partir de cette
annonce là le 27 qu'on a perdu toute
trace de notre pirate informatique
l'action avait commencé au milieu de la
nuit en Bulgarie
le 27 janvier 2021 on a fait une action
coordonnée avec les autorités
américaines bulgares et canadiennes
l'enquête a permis de trouver le serveur
qui permettait à nettoyer
on savait que si on le démantelait il ne
pourrait plus fonctionner mais on ne
voulait pas fermer le serveur sans avoir
monsieur Vachon Desjardins en détention
au matin la cavalerie des barques à
Gatineau
le jour de l'opération on peut dire que
le ciel est tombé complètement sur la
tête ce jour-là on était plusieurs à
travailler ensemble pour que tout se
passe simultanément
c'était excitant
cette journée-là
il y avait beaucoup de gens d'impliqués
quand on est arrivé chez eux la GRC on
fête leur entrée
c'était une journée très froide il y
avait des bandes partout quand je suis
rentré dans sa résidence c'est lorsque
je me suis aperçu que notre travail est
juste commencé
on avait beaucoup beaucoup d'appareils
numériques avec les ordinateurs il y
avait des laps
mon rôle c'était de faire la lecture du
mandat d'arrestation pour l'enquête des
États-Unis
à Sébastien Bachon de jardin je suis
rentré avec mon collègue puis
il était comme un peu content de nous
voir c'est sûr qu'il me connaissait lui
qui est assis et menotté
je procède à son arrestation je suis
allé avec lui dans sa chambre pour se
vêtir nous regardait puis ils ont
vraiment fait la demande nostalgique je
peux toujours rester avec vous j'ai
mentionné que non que c'était pour notre
enquête qu'on était là seulement pour
l'arrêter ça impliquait le FBI puis la
GRC donc la perquisition s'est faite
puis nous on a quitté avec lui
une fois qu'il a été arrêté ils ont
fouillé la maison ont retiré les
ordinateurs les données et des preuves
en sont sortis ainsi que les
informations sur les comptes bancaires
et les montants en Bitcoin il y avait
aussi une quantité considérable d'argent
on a vu des mafieux maître de l'argent
dans leur chaussettes Sébastien lui
gardait son magot sous ses pantoufles il
y avait beaucoup d'argent dans son
garde-robe dans sa chambre à coucher on
parle de
300000 dollars en cache on a trouvé des
clés de coffret de sûreté qui était dans
sa table de chevet
[Musique]
dans deux succursales la Banque
Nationale à Gatineau ou Sébastien Vachon
Desjardins a caché un autre 400 000
dollars
mais ça c'était de la petite monnaie en
comparaison de la crypto monnaie nous
avons récupéré 719 Bitcoin ce qui
représente plusieurs millions de dollars
la valeur était au-dessus de 30 millions
de dollars canadiens
c'est la plus grande quantité de Bitcoin
que nous ayons jamais saisi il y a aussi
une mine d'or d'information dans les
ordinateurs de Sébastien en terme de
données on a saisi l'équivalent de 20 tt
si on avait imprimé toutes ces données
là on aurait pu remplir une araignée au
complète en papier
une fois qu'on a saisi ces appareils on
a eu un portrait bien plus clair de ce
qu'il faisait et du nombre de victimes
canadienne de connu qui était relié avec
Monsieur Vachon Desjardins on a commencé
une enquête contacter les victimes
canadiennes puis pouvoir essayer d'avoir
leur collaboration
parmi elles le collège la cité à Ottawa
Sébastien leur a extorqué l'équivalent
de 300000 dollars en Bitcoin à son
propre collège c'est là où il avait
étudié l'informatique je m'attendais pas
à voir autant de réticences les
compagnies l'enquêteur croyait que les
victimes de Sébastien seraient très
heureuses de collaborer avec la police
c'était le parti le plus difficile de
l'enquête une majorité des victimes n'a
pas porté plainte des cabinets d'avocats
des grosses boîtes immobilières
pharmaceutiques des entreprises
manufacturières
[Musique]
à vouloir reporter les crimes à la
police parce que les compagnies vont eux
sont responsables aussi pour gérer leur
réputation notre groupe challenge c'est
d'aller chercher le plus d'informations
possibles pour pouvoir aussi les
rembourser éventuellement en attente de
son extradition aux États-Unis Sébastien
dis-moi en prison puis un beau matin de
novembre 2021 on reçoit un appel comme
quoi que Monsieur Vachon Desjardins veut
collaborer avec nous et après à faire un
entrevue
[Musique]
c'était moi qui était en charge d'un
interrogatoire et mener sur une période
de deux journées au pénitencier de
Gatineau c'était quelque chose qui était
vraiment gros quand tu reçois un appel
de ton suspect qui dit bon mais ok
maintenant je suis prêt à m'asseoir en
face de toi soit à table puis de te dire
qu'est-ce que c'était passé
des employés ou ce qui avait dans le
fond et tout ce qui est sensible c'est
une terrible
auquel quand
on allait aussi voler les données de
l'entreprise
par exemple numéro d'assurance sociale
et donner médicales
toute information bancaire le mieux aux
employés ou à l'entreprise on était
capable à travers cette entrevue
d'identité des victimes qu'on avait pas
trois mois plus tard en février 2022 il
plaide coupable et il est condamné à 7
ans de prison pour les attaques qu'il
amenaient au Canada
les États-Unis l'attendent maintenant de
pied ferme
le réseau networker était très actif il
y avait environ 400 victimes partout
dans le monde dans 30 pays différents
deux tiers des victimes étaient aux
États-Unis et Monsieur Vachon Desjardins
étaient personnellement responsable pour
plus d'une centaine d'entre elles
[Musique]
Sébastien naufre aucune résistance il
accepte d'être extradé aux États-Unis et
plaide coupable rapidement en juin cette
année
après la pause on vous amène à tempo en
Floride ou Sébastien Vachon Desjardins
va connaître le sort que lui réserve la
justice américaine
c'est le plus gros cas de rançon
logiciel de ma carrière
[Musique]
on vous amène à tempor en Floride ça va
être la conclusion de l'histoire
Sébastien Vachon Desjardins dans
quelques minutes il va être amené devant
un juge dans l'immeuble que vous voyez
derrière moi et c'est là qui va savoir
combien de temps il ira en prison
ce matin Sébastien Vachon Desjardins n'a
qu'un seul allié Marco Bryan son avocat
[Musique]
tu es arrivé au Palais de Justice
fédéral de campa vers 10h30 Sébastien
était évidemment très nerveux je ne
devais être un support moral comme sa
famille et ses amis qui soucient
profondément de lui et je prends cette
responsabilité au sérieux Sébastien
entre escorté par des gardiens Sébastien
était assis juste à côté de moi dans la
salle d'audience le procureur de la
poursuite était à environ 10 pieds de
moi lui aussi est un peu fébrile c'est
le plus gros cas de rançon logiciel de
ma carrière
il a eu bien part d’échapper Sébastien
avant son arrestation
dans ces communication on a découvert
qu'il prévoyait faire des voyages on
était inquiet avec ses antécédents et la
grosse somme d'argent qu'on avait pas
encore trouvé qu'il quitte le pays et
qu'on ne puisse pas l'arrêter
le juge William John de la Cour fédérale
entre et commence l'audience espérant sa
clémence Marco Bryan lui relate son
premier contact avec son client canadien
Sébastien a dit Marc j'ai mal agi je
suis responsable j'ai fait du mal
je ne veux pas contester l'extradition
je veux venir aux États-Unis et dire au
juge que j'ai commis ce crime et que je
suis désolé c'était son but dès le
départ et c'est très inhabituel c'est sa
seule carte il n'y a pas vraiment de
circonstances atténuantes
il a grandi dans un milieu tout à fait
normal avec deux parents aimants il
gagnait bien sa vie il a fait des études
il n'y avait rien qui permettait de
croire qu'il allait commettre des crimes
comme ça
sa motivation c'était l'appât du gain
monsieur Vachon Desjardins voulait faire
de l'argent le plus vite possible et il
aurait pu arrêter après quelques
millions mais il ne l'a pas fait
puisqu'il appelait du coupable les deux
avocats se sont entendus pour une
suggestion commune au
jugement dans cet entente en échange de
son plaidoyer de culpabilité nous avons
assuré à Monsieur Vachon Desjardins que
nous demanderions une peine entre 13 et
14 ans c'est le minimum dans la
jurisprudence 14 ans de prison pour des
crimes informatiques ça peut sembler
énorme comme peine au Canada mais depuis
l'attaque qui a paralysé
est devenu une grande priorité aux
États-Unis
les États-Unis est autre pays de l'Ouest
ont vraiment mis de la pression sur le
gouvernement russe pour qu'il s'attaque
à ses organisations criminelles qui
agissent en toute impunité
la Russie a réagi à cette pression mais
après le déclenchement de la guerre en
Ukraine l'Ouest était de nouveau coincé
Sébastien était plus facile à atteindre
que c'est complices
pour nous au moment de le condamner le
juge exprime son indignation
le juge a comparé Sébastien Vachon
Desjardins a un Jesse James numérique
[Musique]
l'analogie c'est qu'il y a 200 ans les
vols de banque ça se passait à cheval
avec un fusil
maintenant ces crimes sont commis avec
un ordinateur
je pense que la comparaison est juste ce
n'est pas simplement un vol ou un
cambriolage chez de l'extorsion ce qui
rend le crée mon corps moins sympathique
c'est lorsqu'on mesure les conséquences
sur les plus vulnérables
[Musique]
c'est une somme d'argent importante avec
laquelle nous aurions pu soutenir les
membres de cette communauté 370
000 dollars ça aurait nourri bien du
monde ici
ce n'est pas un crime sans victime pas
du tout un crime sans victime
contrairement à d'autres pattes et Giuli
ne seront pas remboursés parce que ce
sont des complices de Sébastien et non
lui-même qui les a attaqués have you
agains
Sébastien n'a fourni aucune information
sur ses complices
coopérer contre d'autres individus non
seulement ça te met en péril pendant la
détention mais ça met à famille et tes
amis à risque c'est un monde dangereux
Sébastien choisit et c'est son droit
d'accepter sa punition et d'aller de
l'avant
[Musique]
il y a un peu de Saint Félicien dans
cette grande enquête internationale la
première fois j'ai entendu le nom de
Sébastien Vachon Desjardins c'est par
l'enquêteur au dossier on m'a dit que
l'ensemble des données que j'avais
fournée aux autorités policières t'ont
fait en sorte que ils ont pu à la fois
avec la GRC et la rivière faire des
croisements
contrairement à bien des victimes de
rançongiciels le cégep a annoncé
publiquement l'attaque
a coûté près d'un million à titre
d'exemple le service préventif la
surveillance du crédit pour les 1000
étudiants à coûter plus de 660 000
dollars c'est un bon deux ans avant de
se remettre complètement lorsqu'un
vendeur on a toujours le choix il y a
des institutions qui décident de ne pas
le dire nous on a décidé de jouer la
carte de transparence il y a aucune
entreprise qui est à l'abri de se faire
pirater ses données donc c'est un
problème de société qui concerne tout le
monde au Québec et au Canada on est très
critique on va les organisations qui
sont victimes de cyberata en général ça
les incite à payer des rançons pour pas
que ça sache ce qui encourage également
les groupes criminels comme networkout
heureusement le cégep a reçu de bonnes
nouvelles grâce à l'enquête menée par la
GRC le montant de près d'un million de
dollars va être repayé au Cégep de
Saint-Félicien donc on est très content
parce que j'avais peu d'espoir
mon manif fait aussi partie de la
poignée de victimes qui seront
partiellement remboursés
la GRC m'a demandé de fournir une
déclaration dédommagement donc c'est
uniquement à ce moment-là qui a eu un
lien clair entre notre attaque du 17
janvier 2021 et notre attaquant qui
était Sébastien Vachon Desjardins ils
ont été extrêmement chanceux non
seulement leur pirate a été arrêté mais
notre espoir dans tout ça c'était que le
FBI est saisi les données qui étaient la
propriété de la ville de Montmagny mais
également les clés de déchiffrement les
clés de chiffrement ont fonctionné tout
est réapparu comme une baguette magique
donc nos experts pour eux c'était du
jamais vu ils nous ont dit sauf qu'il
gagna la loterie c'est un phénomène
aussi rare dans les deux cas donc ça a
été une vague de grands soulagement on
s'est ouvert une petite bouteille de vin
et puis on en a profité il y a un poids
sur les épaules qui venait de tomber
malheureusement ne pas gagner on a été
plus chanceux de notre expérience de
cyberattaque qui a gagné à la à la
loterie Sébastien lui n'a pas tiré le
bon numéro aujourd'hui le juge John dit
to hundred and fury
240 mois le juge a décidé de aller vers
une peine plus sévère et lui donner la
peine maximale pour l'accusation 20 ans
de prison
20 ans c'est le prix à payer en Floride
pour des cyberattaques qui ont fait 400
victimes dans 30 pays
évidemment on espérait une peine moins
sévère c'est mieux que 21 ans on n'est
pas aussi bon que 19 ans
si j'avais rencontré Sébastien Vachon
Desjardins je ne sais pas à quel point
il comprend l'impact humain en arrière
tout ça
pour faire durant son logiciel puis
avoir aussi gros montant c'est ça fait
pas de sens je pense c'est quelqu'un qui
pense pas peut toujours avoir plus pas
capable s'arrêter
avec une bonne conduite le pirate de
Gatineau ne peut espérer sortir d'ici
que dans 17 ans il aura alors la
cinquantaine bien entamée
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié le
reportage de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
je vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]